el agua es una fotero esto significa que
puede actuar como un ácido o como una
base así que pensemos que esta molécula
del agua es un ácido bronze del nou ring
lo que quiere decir que va a ser un
donador de protones y esta otra molécula
del agua vamos a pensarla como una base
bronstein lo que decir que va a ser un
aceptar de protones así que este par de
electrones de aquí lo que va a pasar con
ellos es que se van a pegar a este
protón de aquí por lo tanto va a dejar a
estos electrones detrás y esto va a
formar un nitro neo así que tenemos por
aquí al petróleo tengo un oxígeno por
aquí voy a tener un hidrógeno aquí tengo
otro hidrógeno y por acá voy a tener a
otro hidrógeno h 3 o más aquí voy a
tener un par de electrones y una carga
formal positiva y bueno por otra parte
déjame poner con rojo a estos otros dos
electrones que bueno se van a pegar
justo a este hidrógeno y para formar
justo este enlace que tenemos aquí y es
por eso que obtenemos
h tres o más y en el proceso
déjame ponerlo con color verde vamos a
tener a este par de electrones que se va
a desprender justo de aquí van a
desprenderse de este oxígeno y bueno
déjame dibujar que vamos a obtener vamos
a obtener un oxígeno un hidrógeno aquí
tenemos un enlace y bueno tenemos aquí
un par de electrones otro par de
electrones y con este color verde son
estos electrones que tenemos aquí estos
de verde y es justo por esto que vamos a
tener una carga formal negativa de
uniones de hidróxido esta es la
autoorganización del agua y podemos
escribir una expresión de equilibrio
para esta reacción podemos escribir que
acá
y para esta reacción en especial que es
lo mismo que acá w la cual es llamada la
constante de auto ionización la
constante constante de autoorganización
auto ionización
sesión o también se le conoce con el
nombre del producto iónico del agua
la constante constante
del producto biónico del producto
y único
ahora bien puede tener este nombre este
nombre o puede ser cualquier término que
tú uses o que usen tus libros de texto
lo importante aquí es recordar que
cuando estamos escribiendo una expresión
de equilibrio entonces vamos a poner la
concentración de los productos sobre la
concentración de los reactivos y bueno
si nos fijamos en la concentración de
nuestros productos tenemos primero la
concentración de h3 o positivo de la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno el
cual tiene una carga formal positiva por
la concentración de o h negativo de
acciones de hidróxido y bueno si nos
fijamos nosotros en la concentración de
los reactivos no te preocupes porque la
concentración de los reactivos es agua
pura por lo tanto no la contamos ahora
bien la concentración de lyon de
hidrógeno esto que voy a poner ahorita
de color rojo esta concentración ha sido
determinada experimentalmente en el agua
pura a 25 grados celsius y esta
concentración es lo mismo que 1
0 por 10 a la menos siete molar muy bien
y si nos fijamos en la concentración de
iones de hidróxido deja ponerlo con
color azul cuando la calculamos de una
manera experimental obtenemos que es
exactamente la misma que la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno es
decir que la concentración de iones de
hidróxido en el agua pura a 25 grados
celsius es 1.0 por 10 a la menos 7 molar
y bueno ya con esto podemos calcular que
w porque k w
es la multiplicación de estos dos cierto
y si hacemos la multiplicación de estos
dos podemos decir que la constante de
autoorganización del agua es lo mismo
que cada w que es igual a 1.0 1.0 por 10
a la menos 14 molar
así que si nosotros subimos y le
escribimos aquí me va a quedar 1.0
10 a la menos 14 molar y bueno como esta
constante es mucho menor que 1 nosotros
sabemos que las constantes menores que 1
tienden a tener un equilibrio hacia este
sentido hacia la izquierda esto es
porque tenemos una concentración muy
pequeña de iones de estos y bueno esta
es la auto ionización del agua
ahora vamos a pensar en la concentración
de hidrógeno comparado con la
concentración de hidróxido y para eso
déjame bajar un poco la pantalla y vamos
a escribir lo siguiente en este caso me
quedo que la concentración de iones de
hidrógeno fue exactamente igual que la
concentración de acciones de hidróxido y
en el caso en el que pase eso dejé
escribirlo por aquí en el caso en el que
la concentración de h3 o más sea
exactamente igual a la concentración de
uniones de hidróxido en este caso
decimos que nuestra sustancia o la cosa
con la que estamos trabajando es neutra
neutra ahora vamos a pensar qué pasa si
tenemos una mayor cantidad de la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno una
mayor cantidad que la concentración de
uniones de hidróxido
en este caso cuando pasa o sucede esto
estamos hablando de una sustancia ácida
ácida
y ahora si pensamos en lo contrario en
el caso en el que tenemos una
concentración de iones de hidrógeno
menor a la concentración de iones de
hidróxido en este caso bueno para
hablamos de una solución básica básica
de lujo así que con esto veamos un
problema imagínate que nosotros tomamos
un poco de jugo de limón y bueno
experimentalmente nos damos cuenta que
este jugo de limón tiene una
concentración de iones de hidrógeno de
iones de hidrógeno de no ser
supongamos 2.2 por 10 a la menos 3 molar
y nosotros lo que queremos saber es cuál
es la concentración de hidróxido de
hidróxido cuál es esta concentración y
bueno una vez que ya tenemos esta
concentración será muy bueno clasificar
la solución será esta solución neutra
o ácida o básica y bueno podemos
resolver este problema y encontrar la
concentración de estos aviones de
hidróxido usando la ecuación que
teníamos acá arriba vamos a recordarla
esta ecuación de aquí la cual nos dice
que la concentración de los iones de
hidrógeno por la concentración de los
iones de hidróxido esto es igual a k w a
1.0 por 10 a la menos 14 así que vamos a
utilizar justo eso para resolver este
problema vamos a escribirlo la
concentración de h3 o positivo de iones
de hidrógeno por la concentración de o h
negativo de aniones de hidróxido esto es
igual a 1.0 por 10 a la menos 14 molar y
bueno si tenemos ahora esta
concentración ahora podemos utilizarla y
sustituirla justo aquí y entonces nos va
a quedar que esta concentración que es
2.2
10 a la menos 3 esto va a multiplicar a
la concentración de uniones de hidróxido
lo cual vamos a decir que es equis y
esto va a ser igual a 1.0 por 10 a la
menos 14 ok y si queremos despejar la x
bueno pues habrá que pasar dividiendo
este para la cam así que x que es lo que
queremos la concentración de neones de
hidróxido esto va a ser igual a la
división de este entre éste y para eso
voy a traer por acá a mi calculadora
vamos a hacer lo 1.0 por 10 a la menos
14 esto lo voy a dividir entre 2.2 por
10 a la menos 3 esto me va a dar de
respuesta 4.54 por 10 a la menos 12 así
que vamos a escribirlo esto nos va a dar
de respuesta 4.54
10 al menos 12 y esa es la concentración
que buscábamos de iones de hidróxido y
ahora sí vamos a comparar nuestras
concentraciones por aquí o espera olvide
poner aquí molar muy bien vamos a
comparar esta concentración la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno que
es 2.2 por 10 en la menos 3 molar con la
concentración de iones de hidróxido que
es 4.54 por 10 a la menos 12 molar y
bueno si subo un poco la pantalla para
ver en qué caso estamos bueno date
cuenta de lo siguiente 2.2 por 10 a la
menos 3 molar este número de aquí es
mucho más grande que este número de
aciertos que 4.54 por 10 a la menos 12
molar estás de acuerdo 2.2 por 10 a la
menos 3 molar es más grande que 4.54 por
10 a la menos 12 molar es decir que
estamos en este caso de aquí en el caso
en el que la concentración de iones de
trono es más grande que la concentración
de iones de hidróxido podemos concluir
que la solución es ácida
jugo de limón es una solución ácida